this week we've got dog rescue oh he
pistol a cemetry oh my god
cemetry dog rescue boys I'm gonna tell
you right now this dog rescued its damn
self
Sal kind of so let's get my dog before I
get to try think about my rescue dog no
I'm not really good it took a meatloaf
out into the ocean because I knew he
wanted to swim so we would I swam all
the way out with him and then he kept
trying to turn back because I think he
didn't like it anymore so I kept turning
him back towards the ocean and I kept
swimming with him and then this fool I
started so first he was like this and
then pretty soon like his head started
going underwater and more and then you
see his fur like getting soaked into the
water of it
oh [ __ ] I think this was really tough
but my feet can't even touch the floor
they were pretty oh my god that's like
tried to help him I'm like not the
swimmer back to [ __ ] was I you're
probably on the side the other dogs I
saved them no you put him in knew you
wanted to swim so bad idea
last month I saved my dog we went hiking
and you know how it's been raining like
crazy so the the trail that we go to the
creek turned into a whitewater rapid
river it was pretty crazy I'm
exaggerating wasn't that crazy [ __ ]
lie okay I'm not gonna lie alright but
there but let me tell you the tallest
[ __ ] happen alright so there was a
there was a there was a there was like a
log that we could walk over and so all
three of us were walking and I had this
clumsy [ __ ] ass dog named Sophie and
she slipped and I was hanged she was
hanging by my [ __ ] leash and I was
like oh [ __ ] and then she's trying to
climb back up like choking what she had
a harness on since she was like this
she was like this right and I was like
oh but the water and current was so
strong she was trying to go against the
current and then she was in the wool she
was going in her head was going in the
water and I was like Oh [ __ ] I couldn't
pick her back up so I jumped off and I
went down like on a rock like this I was
like hanging on a rock and I was pulling
her in and I [ __ ] rescued her ass and
I was like [ __ ] yeah Baywatch okay so
there's a this is happening Thailand and
there's a group of people like people
working they were on an oil rig
and they see this dog just like out in
the middle of the ocean I'm just
imagining them out there and they're
like but do you see this so here's a
picture of the dog loved dogs it's a
cute puppy trainer yeah poor guy they so
they found they found him out in the
middle of the the ocean he was basically
a hundred and thirty six miles away from
Shores yeah so they realized the dog had
swam like that far they don't really
know what happens
would you let six would it be interview
the dog pulling the crab net and there's
a [ __ ] dog like just chill it's like
totally alive and fine maybe he fell off
the boat or something yeah they're not
well that's true too but they're
assuming that he came from shore and
just like got out there and I think it's
kind of sad because like I'm imagining
him just like just like okay if I just
keep swimming like I'll get there soon
but he was actually getting like deeper
into the ocean that was stupid he went
the wrong way Google Maps Google Maps
and just to give you guys an idea for a
human to swim a mile it takes about 45
to 50 minutes so like I'm assuming like
see ruff yeah what I mean I'm thinking
my dog would be slower a I don't know I
mean like what kind of
human that's like doing this yeah yeah
this is like for like an Olympic like
average like how long to swim a mile
said one we'll take 45 to 50 minutes for
a mile including breaks he had to have
fallen off a boat then you're gonna die
you think so 100% meatloaf we maybe went
a hundred feet and this fool is trying
to go ahead not wear it lower yeah I
think he fell off a bullet because he
would know to swim back to shore
why is he going away from the shore yeah
that makes sense yeah that does make
sense cuz but yeah he wasn't my mans was
just out there he was hungry he was cold
and or maybe he's an alien
maybe he's named in a dog oh and he was
beamed down I don't know like this looks
like a dog I'm up steady I'm just
dropping mom might happen that's what
they do
don't seals look like dogs to you like
aren't they the dogs of the Seas yeah
they fart - yeah yeah you're like there
is a sea version for everything on land
like dolphins are the human sea version
of you oh it's dolphin I think dolphins
are human they also they have like legs
they don't have any legs and tips like
but they do have a clitoris yes they do
do they really yes they do casters
dolphin clitoris and you can see because
they said that the clitoris is inside
the vagina do they rub it for women it's
on the outside right but for dolphin
with it
do they eat each other out like 69 and
they spin in a circle is old elegant
making water bowls we had an entire
episode of what we were researching
penises like different animal penis it's
pretty sure gone yeah then you guys just
party way too hard we're gone what the
[ __ ]
cuz dolphin penis are huge it's weird
shape - his name
dal-su why like I click curiosity don't
crabs have like armored penises what oh
my god that sounds amazing
wait but they have armored vaginas so
they can take beyond with pain I hope no
it opens it opens so the vagina well
they don't really have a vagina they
have the egg you know yeah yeah and then
so because you can only eat the male
crab of the Dungeness crab and in the
way you know is you look at it and it's
a small triangle then it's a dick and
then it goes out like this so then the
crab shows like this and then it's like
it's like a ramp it goes like that
yeah there's a there's a dick that comes
out and I don't think they penetrate I
think they just shoot sperm into this
mic in order to get pregnant I have to
catch it oh my god misconduct generation
this just [ __ ] drops the eggs and
then the other fish comes it's like two
airplanes [ __ ] with bombs and [ __ ]
you know like one drops the egg the
other one drops the come and then you
just hope that it catches ya okay so
here's the team that found the dog
screen protectors oh crap pink helmet
[Laughter]
yeah that's future me IV
[Music]
and it's funny that they actually got a
picture if I'm looking like so happy
yeah looks so different
he's less sad I you know I just based
off the before and after his mood I
think he did swim a hundred and
thirtysomething miles damn that's crazy
i'ma go with da
I feel like dogs are humans trapped in
the soul of an animal like a child
that's trapped what it's been [ __ ]
okay we need to release that soul how do
we do that what are your thoughts on
that you have science okay now I don't
want to kill them but science I'm gonna
Janet Rick and Morty episode where you
put the Hat on the dog oh my god I love
that episode thinking of science a
senior citizen began spraying people
with his own urine with a water gun
that's science what so he peed into a
Wichita that's fence and he's blasting
people chemistry pee science okay segue
work no yeah yeah yeah okay
so Joel Benjamin 71 years old let me
show with you guys what the pee pee man
looks like he looks like a P now I want
y'all to remember look at this face and
we'll get to a story but he claims he
has no remorse he said he would look
like we have no remorse he would
absolutely do it again what he said
about the dumpling well he didn't really
express why but like the people that I'm
not sure if it's the people who got peed
on or the witnesses but they think that
he was just reacting to people not
taking care of their animals like
picking up after them and like not like
just keeping a hold on him he's just a
grumpy old I agree with him pick up like
the dogs poop and stuff that don't pick
avenge towards them yeah I wonder if his
water gun was the squirt Kyle where does
little streams right or is it like a
super soaker it looks like it's like a
pea to fill up a super soaker or the one
with the backpack he's probably banging
into a bucket and he has
just months with something that I could
smell that I'm actually cool with this I
think there's a lot of like [ __ ] I
don't know how people just can't be
decent and pick up their dog [ __ ] like
that just blows my mind yeah it's the
most simplest [ __ ] on earth but you know
if you live in a area that has a lot of
pets they people [ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah yeah
you should even have a pet I've sent a
picture of the water gun he already had
this on hand so I guess that's my old
dude walking up to you and like he pulls
that out but it's you're like oh oh he's
old it's gonna be water this is gonna be
a fun time we're all gonna you yeah
that's the one thing that's a file photo
of oh excuse me a file photo of a water
pistol it was easy it wasn't the actual
one but that's the that's the one that's
one scored at a time yeah yeah so was
the only spraying people that weren't
picking up after the doggies or was it
like did he just go rampaging they
didn't they didn't really like we have
all the details I'm not like people like
they're just like witnesses or assuming
but he said when he was interrogated he
showed no remorse and then they when
they talked to about it he was like I'd
do it again I'd do it oh I'm surprised
he didn't have [ __ ] grenades to hang on
this front yard is probably all these
dogs shouldn't and no one's picking it
up he's tired of it yeah yeah yeah he
actually the first person he approached
was a fifty year old victim who was in
her with with her dog on a Saturday
night and he says he allegedly pulled
out the pea filled water pistol on the
50 year-old victim that's tight
literally pulled out a pea pistol well
if that victim was always responsible
and picking up dog [ __ ] they did not
deserve it yeah I don't even know I
don't even know if the dog poop yeah
maybe he might have just been mad about
how many animals nearby maybe there was
a puppy part maybe he lived there for 40
year detective Joe did he live there for
40 years I'm on his side oh yeah I like
this guy Joe Joe's on some get off my
lawn [ __ ] I am I think the older I'm
getting the more I'm just like judgy
like how can there be [ __ ]
litter in the middle of this nature
trail like why do you have this now and
later pack on the [ __ ] floor like why
dad I just not even a water bottle like
why what's going on here well now I like
it
further animal news this one this one's
a sad one yeah alright I'm gonna show
you what she looked like first cuz crazy
alright oh she's got murder eyes yes she
she got I'm gonna I'm gonna show you
guys a little bit more but I just I want
you to have a visual yet she does have
those are those eyes normal um cuz they
look like your cat intense they're like
look like cat oh she looked like she
won't kill me yes she does so this is
Casey Casey burger Casey barely seemed
like a pretty normal person she uh she
lists on her social media owner owner of
strength power weight owner strength
size powerlifting coach sports
nutritionist at next level Fitness it
was a Christian theme like training gym
she was posting a lot of like Christian
quotes like real nice girl obviously is
she would you know she looked a little
crazy oh she got Jesus in her eyes she
got Jesus you know now she loves she
loves cats she loves to be surrounded in
cash so that's nice nice pre-workout oh
yeah you think it's all the pre-workout
so she beautiful eyes oh look at that
yeah and then she also she works out a
lot you know she be she be at the eyes
look normal there
they don't look cousin she does look
pissed though she does look at her mouth
never smile yeah though now she was
never alone she had cats and she didn't
have like just like one or two
I got God
she had um she had a lot of cats and buy
a lot of cats we mean about a hundred
and forty four cows
[Music]
yeah she obtained one hundred and forty
four cats from the animal Humane Society
and kept them at their Farmington area
house that she rented she rented this
house of a hundred yeah I know what
would possess a woman that's 26 years
old to just start like collecting cats
like that like you know I sold at the
work the place that I worked before I
worked with like a lot of like older
people and there's this woman knew there
was this woman named Elaine and she had
a she had a cat named Pikachu and I was
like oh that's cute she was like I used
to have fourteen of them and uh really
she was like City came and took them
away oh my god why I mean I was like
talking to her balance she was like like
she didn't give me to me details but
later on people told me that she had
free-roaming cats so they would run
around the front yard they run around
the backyard like she had a really small
apartment and like the neighbors were
like yo you need to get your cat's dog
like I don't I don't understand what it
is when people just start collecting
cats like this other than forty forty
though like that's I can't even imagine
what that looks like I have room well
it's not because when authorities
searched the house sixty-four of the
cats were dead oh my god and they
described it as a absolute nightmare why
does that [ __ ] it might be does it look
like showing I I don't know what I'm
looking at that is not healthy oh my god
I thought that was the backyard
mmm no dude this is what that's her home
yeah this is yes she's disgustingly good
well it's just a rental and there is
someone out there that will [ __ ] her oh
[Applause]
that's how you know do you think that's
nasty guys are nasty her they'll go yeah
they'll go in that house like [ __ ] it
and then they would bomb the crap out of
her
take her in the car they would lay her
down on top of the cat [ __ ] and bone the
crapper serious question if you met girl
at a bar she was good enough for the
night and you went back to her house you
know in question is very auditions how
fine is she exactly you're not in the
right one how drunk am i and how horny
right good for the night Rainey yeah but
then there's pop the home all your
things good no
so you're sober you're sober but you
just went to a breakup oh I'm [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of him grab the captain or
to the side be like close the whole time
you would put my nose up baby
I want some of this [ __ ] you this
something like this how does it help
allergic to I'll be like itching while
I'm buggin doggies powder like [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah I feel like that should be
such an indicator that she probably
doesn't take care of herself like oh
yeah yeah that's the eyelid thing there
has to be some kind of psychic
psychological imbalance like we
absolutely oh she's got to be that's got
to be one of those situations like you
know like if you if you watch porn and
like you know you just start getting to
the nasty [ __ ] you're like yeah this is
fine you know it's like going to her
house and it's like this is the nasty
[ __ ] you like yeah this is fine and then
when you're dying you're like all of a
sudden you smell it's pretty gross now
you snapped out of it huh
not really no well it depends on my mind
state I told you guys I [ __ ] up oh man
I mean he's not alone bars right there
with them damn I mean I don't know like
you get a really hot girl right yeah
thanks for a month like way out of your
league - by the way it's it's like
someone like what if it's like a
celebrity or someone that you've and
you're like oh my god is my only chance
I can't believe they want me right and
then and then and then they pull you out
to the back morals like really
or the talkative girl you talk to four
girls at the club they all rejected you
and finally the fifth one was we're
going to give you a chance yeah but to
the point you see that room and then
you're like you have morals and staff
okay okay let me let me let me make it a
little bit more milder okay
so this the hottest girl like you just
like oh my god can't believe this is
happening to me this is amazing right
she takes you to the back alley she goes
I want you to [ __ ] me right now next to
these dumpsters makes it as crackhead
that's watching us that turns me on
yeah there's no cat poop everywhere you
know but but but but you know what I
think it depends like if we just nut it
or we it's like oh okay so my question
for you I just had sex I don't love you
I don't want I don't want to be with you
so extra details the home also had a few
dogs and a pig what the pig was a free
roaming Pig that would just run or a
half outside animal hoarder what
punishment do you think hello what do
y'all think she should have got who the
[ __ ] is her let her [ __ ] the landlord
who the [ __ ] is the landlord if they
kind of a listen why is it just animal
cruelty right yeah pleaded guilty to 13
counts of mistreatment of animals only
30 felony
well so she gets a couple years of
probation
a couple hundred hours of community
service three months on house arrest
she's no longer allowed to own animals
and she had three days of jail why three
that's not random I feel like she was
mentally needs a little help she should
put on the show hoarders I love that
show oh my god have you seen animal
hoarders version do you ever you know
what the secret is oh my god the secret
to life is putting hoarders on why you
have to clean
patience yes yes I've done that before
it gets I'm not a hoarder I'm a
world-class collector